[Music]
it's a simple extraction we go into
space we get the astronauts we bring
them home any questions yeah like a
thousand we don't have time for a
thousand doing space missions now cool
let's go
[Music]
that's a solar flare you know I've never
seen a reading like this Kurt take Peter
go
right back
[Music]
[Music]
has a sound if you break something I can
fix it I have a school for young people
who are like eug we could be your new
family if you like go qureishi where is
she
she should be dead whatever happened up
there made her stronger she's changing
it what
I'm scared I mean is control bad things
happen to people I watch I'm not giving
up on Yugi this is what family does we
take care of each other so that power
destroyed everything that ever came into
contact with until you
what they don't understand they fear
and what they fear we seek to destroy by
you scared little girl who answers to a
man in a chair are you the most powerful
creature on the planet
this is your choice tell me how we fix
this trust tell me what to do don't know
what to do
girl dies she's still June we can still
help sometimes we want to believe people
are something that they are not ever the
time realize who they are
it's too late
she's coming
[Music]